Democrats are getting testy over having
to defend Joe Biden against a sexual
assault allegation for example here's a
Nancy Pelosi do you view this as it
closed the issue and what is your
response well it is for me I have said I
am proud to support Joe Biden for
president I believe him when he says it
didn't happen but I also believe him
when he says let them and look into the
records and that's what they should do
but I'm not going to answer this
question again all right Juan is that
good enough for Nancy Pelosi she just
said it's good enough but you know I'm
gonna you know say something to you
Jesse that I think most Democrats
wouldn't say I'll just say this as a
political analyst I think lots of
Democrats including I think it's Martin
Tolson who wrote a letter he's the
founder of Politico wrote a letter in
New York Times
he's just being very honest when he says
for lots of Democrats they just would
rather focus on defeating Trump that's
where their energy is and you know that
this issue about the charge the lady's
been heard the story's been reported and
now you have Biden denying it so where
do we go I think this is similar to a
lot of people on the right especially
the evangelicals who in the case of
Trump say you know what we have other
fish to fry we're moving on I think they
have to do it with a lot more charges
than what faces Biden hmm okay so Katie
is that the new standard now if there's
ever an allegation in the middle of a
political run one party just says I
believe them and let's move on and
that's pretty much it
Milan says that the women has been heard
but that's not the standard the standard
is the woman must be believed and that
has been Joe Biden's standard for people
like Brett Kavanaugh and for college
campuses for young men who are simply
accused without any evidence of some
kind of sexual abuse so that's the issue
at hand here is the the own standard the
Democrats have issued for everybody else
so they don't want to hold themselves to
and it's interesting to watch Nancy
Pelosi try to navigate this because you
do have a revolt happening in parts of
the party who are saying
we want a full investigation of Joe
Biden and she's used to all the
Democrats lining up behind and pushing
and brushing this kind of bad behavior
aside whether it's from Ted Kennedy or
Bill Clinton or other people and so now
she's in a political position where she
has to worry about on Capitol Hill what
she's going to do moving forward and
whether they're going to launch some
kind of investigation into Joe Biden
yeah Dana does look like the momentum
clearly is that this needs to be fully
investigated before they move on oh no
they're just gonna move on and they're
gonna be they're gonna point to Joe
Biden's interview and say that's all the
weight they need and they're going to be
quite comfortable with that and kind of
as a result the bigger picture is that
the me2 movement it has collapsed under
the weight of the Democrats hypocrisy
but that will be the consequence that
they face Wow oh good good line all
right Greg take us home well when
they're saying case closed we must move
on what they're saying is we believe the
woman we don't care that because the
fact is Joe has the reputation and
everything and people I actually admire
a lot of these Democrats who are saying
I believe the woman but I'm still voting
for Joe Biden that just says it's you
know but the thing is I want to commend
Joe and rewarding his old dear drunken
pal Chris Dodd with the plum job of
helping to seek the VP the female VP I
want everybody in America watching the
show to go to Google and insert the
words Chris Dodd and waitress which will
detail with witnesses in respectable
places assorted assault with a with a
witness with with witnesses of a young
waitress in a restaurant
so how effing clueless does Joe have to
be to drag Chris Dodd some old white
lets back into the news which will keep
this story alive I mean I guess Harvey
Weinstein was busy making license plates
so we had a pic Chris Dodd Krista why
are you rewarding your old friend who
has a reputation and now they're just
going to keep this story going how
stupid
is Joe Biden that Lots
well at least Christmas and I spend a
lot of money on drinks and tips at
restaurants we definitely know that all
right